for most of human history what we did
for a living was decided for us by our
families we would either directly copy
what our parents did or else we would
referentially accept their suggestions
for what we might do only for around the
last 200 years have we been choosing
jobs for ourselves and we're still at
the beginning of learning some of the
complexities of doing so on the surface
most families claim to have no interest
in their children doing any job in
particular the standard line is that
they simply want us to be happy but we
are not as free as this sounds we are
always hemmed in by what can be termed
family work scripts that is scripts that
guide us often very subtly but also very
heavily towards certain occupations and
away from others part of properly
growing up which may sometimes happen
only in one's 50s means learning to find
a way around the scripts we've been
handed at the most benign level our
family work scripts are the result of
what our families understand of the
working world every family has a range
of occupations that it grasps because
someone has practiced them and in the
process brought them within the
imaginative range of other family
members yet it isn't just a case that
our families might not know about
certain jobs and so might cut us off
from them they might also be positively
hostile or suspicious of other jobs
we're liable to have received many
little messages indicating that certain
careers are inferior and therefore
beneath us maybe dangerous phony
or not quite right for our sort of
station in life whatever lip service
might be paid to gender equality
families are also highly talented at
sending out covert messages about what a
real man or a real woman should
honorably do yet more darkly families
may say that they want us to succeed but
would be highly threatened if we
actually did so a choice we make might
remind someone of their failed ambitions
ass
success might make them feel like a
failure we might try to sabotage our
chances of winning so is not to leave a
loved one feeling crushed often without
realizing it we are being heavily
controlled by our families controlled
not by harsh words but by something far
more poignant and yet far harder to
extricate ourselves from by our ongoing
desire to be a good child to please
those who brought us into this world by
love love can control us as much as
force or the law ever could we are
liable to try to be good children not
just because we feel love but because we
fear losing love because we live in
dread of being cast out if we were to
dare to say what we want but here is the
good news for the timid good children
among us parents very very rarely disown
their progeny it certainly seems they
might in our imaginations forged in
childhood but the adult reality is that
families are extremely good threatening
to break apart but then also at
forgiving one another and accommodating
the most extraordinary challenges and
tests we don't know your families but we
can guess that you could do a lot more
than you think
a lot more that might be a bit bad in
their eyes and still be forgiven we owe
our parents respect and kindness we do
not owe them our lives we should dare
when the pressure has become unbearable
to leave their scripts aside at the
school of life we're constantly
developing new products to help us
develop emotional intelligence to learn
more follow the link on your screen now
you